well it appears to have been a truly
horrifying uh incident that played out
at a kindergarten in the Lian Zhang area
of Guangdong Province that's right in
the very southeast of China it looks
like it happened at sort of school
drop-off time if you like it all started
playing out according to police at about
7 40 this morning just at that time when
people were likely dropping their
children off to kindergarten and what we
know at the moment is that six people
have sadly died three of those are
children uh one is a teacher and two
parents
um as well we don't know a huge amount
about exactly how it played out but the
police have said that a 25 year old man
has been arrested they've given his
surname only as Wu and said that he is
from that area but look this sort of
thing really really rocks China in the
very rare instance that it happens and
the reason for that is that violent
crime of this nature is actually
extremely unusual uh in China and
schools and kindergartens are actually
very highly securitized in a way that
they aren't necessarily in the UK so
even this sort of thing happening is is
much much more difficult and another
thing although these things are rare
there have been a few instances of
kindergarten stabbings in recent years
there were there was one uh last year
and a really particularly terrible one
in 2018 in the city of Chongqing where
14 people died so very very shocking
it's absolutely swept Chinese social
media this morning this instant but
certainly a real real tragedy in the
province of Guangdong